[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
que no se arme luego de que un policía
blanco disparara 7 veces por la espalda
y dejara paralizado al afroamericano
jacov plate el movimiento black light
smarter se tomó las calles de esta
ciudad del estado de wisconsin y hasta
allí llegaron trump y bailen al mismo
tiempo que siguen saliendo a la luz
nuevos casos de presunto abuso contra
los afro estadounidenses en colombia es
el sexto país del mundo en contagios de
kobe 19 y terminó esta semana su
confinamiento ahora solo deberán
permanecer en casa los positivos
aeropuertos parques y restaurantes al
aire libre vuelven a llenarse mientras
el personal médico advierte de las
precarias condiciones en las que trabaja
y san francisco es conocida como la
capital mundial el fbi a raíz de la
pandemia muchos de los negocios más
icónicos para esta comunidad han tenido
que cerrar sus puertas pero otros se
reinventan para evitar correr esa misma
suerte como un club de drag queens que
ha creado un negocio de comida a
domicilio que incluye un show pero
respetando la distancia social
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal y es que siguen y
siguen apilando se los casos de presunto
abuso policial con motivos raciales
esta semana en washington un policía
disparó y mató al afroamericano
dyn key de 18 años en los ángeles de
jong chis y murió cuando agentes
intentaron detenerlo por una supuesta
infracción de tránsito y en nueva york
se conoció el caso de daimiel cruz
ocurrido en marzo que falleció después
de que agentes de rochester lo
detuvieron y le presionaron la cabeza
contra el pavimento todos estos hechos
ocurren en pleno estallido por el caso
de keiko plate en kenosha que recibió
siete disparos de la policía y quedó
paralizado de la cintura a los pies
las cifras son preocupantes según la
agencia de noticias efe desde la muerte
de georg floyd en mineápolis en mayo se
han registrado 387 agresiones ya sea
verbales o amenazando con un arma de
supremacistas blancos a integrantes del
movimiento black life smarter 64 de
éstas han sido agresiones físicas y
nueve veces estas agresiones resultaron
en disparos causando la muerte de tres
personas
y dos de esas muertes ocurrieron
precisamente en que no sea por la tensa
situación el presidente de donald trump
y el candidato demócrata joe biden
visitaron la ciudad y dejaron un mensaje
muy diferente mientras bardem llamó a la
unidad y se reunió con la familia de
blake crump solo dio su apoyo a los
comerciantes cuyos negocios fueron
destruidos por los disturbios que se
registran al margen de las protestas y
esta diferencia ha sido evidente en toda
la campaña veámoslo en el siguiente
informe la diferencia en la retórica no
podría ser más evidente
tenemos que sanar tenemos que organizar
las cosas organizarnos hablar de lo que
debe hacerse y tratar de ver si hay un
comienzo de mecanismo para abrir a la
gente y exiliado de la ola de violencia
y destrucción que hemos visto en las
semanas y meses recientes ha ocurrido en
ciudad es exclusivamente controladas y
dominadas por el partido de jóve
whiteford y mientras uno habla de
división
el otro llama a la unidad es la carrera
a la casa blanca
con donald trump sacando su lema de ley
y orden en cada oportunidad y empujando
a los demócratas a ver más allá de sus
estrategias iniciales de atacar al
presidente por su manejo de la pandemia
con el telón de fondo de las protestas
contra el racismo y el abuso policial
que en ocasiones terminan en violencia
by the end camina sobre una línea
delgada tratando de hacer equilibrio
entre el apoyo incondicional de trump a
las fuerzas de seguridad y los llamados
del ala más izquierdista de su propio
partido que piden una reforma policial
profunda sin embargo incluso el
exvicepresidente ha pedido una revisión
policial
capps la mayoría de los policías son
buenos el hecho de que los malos tienen
que ser identificados y procesados y
salir juntos ha sido cuidadoso en evitar
tomar como propias las metas de from the
police para reasignar los fondos de la
policía algo que el movimiento black
light matter apoya al que bailén ha
alabado
sin embargo las encuestas revelan que
los estadounidenses siguen más
preocupados por la pandemia de
coronavirus que del crimen lo que juega
a favor de la estrategia demócrata
incluso cuando hablan de asuntos civiles
de no declinar saben que no pueden
ignorar el asunto incluso si no cree que
al final el sonido del crimen y el apoyo
a la policía van a ser asuntos clave
cuando decidan por quién votar
yo bailé en aun cree que las
preocupaciones de la salud
específicamente de la pandemia del
hobbit son los asuntos más importantes
en las urnas schmerkin suene con su
doctor
la pregunta continúa siendo si esos
asuntos serán los importantes en los
estados péndulo o bisagra los que no
tienen una tendencia demócrata o
republicana clara donde la verdadera
batalla por la casa blanca se libra
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador ofreció su segundo informe
de gobierno amplio defendió las
estrategias frente a la pandemia del cob
y 19 cuando la nación tiene la mayor
tasa de mortalidad por contagio según la
universidad johns hopkins 10.8 la nación
azteca registra casi 70 mil muertos y ya
superó los 600 mil contagios entre otros
temas el presidente aseguró haber
ahorrado más de 25 mil 800 millones de
dólares
gracias a la lucha contra la corrupción
en medio de la polémica por un vídeo en
el que se ve a su hermano pío recibiendo
dinero del que ahora es un funcionario
de su gobierno
es el gobierno
no será recordado por corrupto
[Música]
nuestro principal legado sera
purificar la vida pública de méxico
y estamos avanzando
no hemos emprendido persecuciones
facciosas ni venganzas políticas
pero tampoco encubrimos a nadie
ni permitimos la impunidad
ya se acabó la robadera de los de arriba
pero todavía falta desterrar por
completo el bandidaje oficial
y vamos a venezuela para revisar otras
noticias del continente que usted
debería conocer esta semana
se desmorona la alianza opositora el ex
candidato presidencial henrique capriles
radonski dijo que era necesario
participar en las elecciones
legislativas de diciembre luego de que
el presidente nicolás maduro otorgará un
indulto a 110 personas entre los que hay
algunos de los denominados presos
políticos pero también delincuentes
comunes e invitará a la onu ya la unión
europea a observar los comercios los 15
partidos políticos que apoyan al
presidente de la opositora asamblea
nacional juan guaidó reconocido por más
de 60 países como el mandatario legítimo
venezolano se mantienen de momento
firmes y sin fisuras en su decisión de
no asistir a esas elecciones
la ex presidenta de costa rica laura
chinchilla renunció a la candidatura de
la presidencia del banco interamericano
de desarrollo en medio de la polémica
que hay por esa elección debido a que
por primera vez en la historia el
presidente de donald trump nomino a un
candidato estadounidense rompiendo con
la tradición de que el líder sea un
latinoamericano
y más que un seguidor conoce la hacienda
española a shakira el diario del país de
españa divulgó la minuciosa
investigación con la que una inspectora
buscaba determinar que la cantante
colombiana no vive en bahamas sino en
españa desde que inició su relación con
el futbolista gerard piqué lo que la
obliga a pagar impuestos en ese país
y sigamos hablando de colombia la sexta
nación del mundo en contagios de kobe 19
sin embargo empezó esta semana su
reapertura en casi todos los sectores de
la economía
sólo habrá confinamiento selectivo es
decir que las únicas personas que
deberán permanecer en casa serán las
positivas por kobe 19 pero el personal
médico sigue trabajando en condiciones
particularmente difíciles veamos el
informe de pascal mariani y simone bruno
8 de la mañana en bogotá maribel acaba
de terminar su turno nocturno en un
hospital sin haber dormido se dirige a
una clínica privada para otra jornada de
trabajo el 80% de los trabajadores de la
salud en todo el país estamos de laboral
izados lo que hace la mayoría es tener
dos o tres trabajos gran parte de la
actividad se ha reanudado la cuarentena
realmente estricta la tuvimos el primer
mes y de ahí en adelante pues se fué
flexibilizando el número de casos de
kobe 19 se ha multiplicado en los
últimos meses a pesar de 5 meses de
confinamiento esta es la paradoja
colombiana en esta clínica
maribel trabaja como refuerzo de la
unidad de cuidados intensivos
este hombre acaba de enterarse de que su
hermano ha muerto de coronavirus
está lista para dar la ronda
los muchachos m
se me derrumbaron se me pusieron a
llorar
que el muchacho que acabo de morir tenía
30 años
dedicado a ser taxista en colombia hay
un divorcio entre el gremio de la salud
y las autoridades
el colegio médico de bogotá y otras
asociaciones de salud hicieron muchas
advertencias sobre el manejo de la
pandemia pero los administradores de lo
publicó hicieron caso omiso y ellos pues
siguieron sus propias líneas
hoy la economía está colapsada y con el
fin del confinamiento los médicos temen
un aumento de los contagios cuando ya
están al límite ya estamos muy cansados
de esa parte emocional que esa parte de
intensidad horaria ya no se impacta
mucho extrañamos nuestras familias el
des confinamiento de inicio las
reuniones seguirán siendo prohibidas
se recomienda el teletrabajo para
quienes pueden pero todos tienen derecho
a circular libremente solo los
contagiados tendrán que quedarse en casa
la apuesta de es arriesgada en un país
donde las pruebas aún son insuficientes
y el sistema de salud es más frágil que
nunca
las drag queens de san francisco tienen
claro que la pandemia del cobi 19 no las
detendrá para evitar tener que cerrar
uno de sus clubs más famosos en la que
es conocida como la capital de gvt y se
adaptaron a las medidas y empezaron a
vender comida a domicilio con un show
incluido aunque eso sí respetando a la
distancia social nos cuenta nuestra
corresponsal en susana mentos
esta es mora una drag queen y está
ofreciendo un show a la clienta a la que
acaba de traer la comida
y eso le da una oportunidad a artistas
gays a quien san francisco es una
bendición estoy feliz de tener esta
oportunidad
es parte del espectáculo que ofrece
meals on wheels o comida sobre tacones
dentro del conocido club de drag queens
oasis
estoy siendo una buena tranquila cuando
vas al backstage a punto de salir a
escena y si te rompe la cremallera o el
dj no tiene tus canciones puedes elegir
entre cancelarlo todo o irte a casa o
agarrar cinta adhesiva una canción que
conoces salir y vender el espectáculo
eso es lo que hemos hecho vender el
espectáculo
la comida se prepara en restaurantes
locales por ahora sólo reparten los
viernes con tres drag queens aunque
piensan ampliar horarios
y realmente se ha vuelto popular creo
que la gente tiene hambre de conectar
con otros seres humanos están
acostumbrados a tener conferencias por
su por videochat quieren ver a otro ser
humano
zamora improvisa con lo que encuentra en
la calle y por un momento vuelve a
encontrarse el aplauso del público con
pandemia o sin pandemia el show debe
continuar
[Aplausos]
y gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí américa recuerden que
pueden seguirme en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas cuídense mucho el
coronavirus si pueden quédense en casa y
sigan viendo france24
[Música]